er kommt zu einem weiteren heißen thema
und da habe ich für sie fünf tipps ja
ein aufregerthema ist das thema
mieterhöhung tatsächlich immer wieder
will der vermieter mehr geld und dafür
habe ich jetzt fünf tipps tipp 1 nicht
jede mieterhöhung ist berechtigt nach
einem bgh-urteil aus diesem sommer gilt
nur wenn eine modernisierung vorliegt
darf der vermieter die kosten um wälzen
und in der definition ist eine
modernisierung eine echte verbesserung
der wohnsituation
tipp 2 werden zum beispiel nur türen
oder briefkästen erneut ist es keine
modernisierung sie müssen dann wissen
das muss der vermieter wird zahlen tipp
sind sie mit einer mieterhöhung nicht
einverstanden damit zahlen sie die miete
fortan nur noch unter vorbehalt dass
können sie dem vermieter so mitteilen
tipp 4 der preisaufschlag darf innerhalb
von drei jahren nicht höher sein als 20
oder sogar 15 prozent also auch da gibt
es regelungen da gibt es eine sogenannte
kappungsgrenze das heißt also immer
darauf achten dass die mieterhöhung wenn
sie berechtigt ist in diesem rahmen
bleibt und tipp 5 auch ganz wichtig wenn
sie sauer sind auf ihren vermieter und
sagen der kann mich jetzt mal dann
wirklich ganz wichtig zahlen 70 euro
miete weil dann riskieren sie natürlich
dass sie der vermieter rauswirft
tatsächlich einzige ausnahme es gibt so
gravierende mängel
das wohnen unzumutbar bleibt